Russian gamers unable to find the line  between reality and fiction has been  calling a pizza place in New Jersey  thinking that it has something to do  with the five nights at Freddy's series  because it's called Freddie's restaurant  and pizzeria presumably not realizing  that Freddie is a pretty common name  fans of the game have been calling the  pizzeria up to 200 times an hour  probably looking for some kind of  confirmation on their fan Terry Esther  who purple guy and the puppet up  unfortunately the restaurant is now  having trouble servicing its actual  customers as its occupied fielding  questions about horrifying animatronic  bears who want to rip your face up the  pizzeria has opened new phone lines and  hide more employees to cover them but  really wishes gamers would just stop  calling unless they actually want pizza  five nights Creator Scott Cawthon has  passed on that there are no phone  numbers associated with the game or  marketing and all locations are  fictional